- All right, y'all.
You know that we can't close up an hour
without one last feel-good story.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
A 12-year-old artist
is helping young black
and brown girls gain
confidence with a series
of coloring books that
include powerful affirmations.
She goes by Summer Strawberry
and says after experiencing bullying,
she wants other kids to have
the tools to get through it.
Let's say hi to the author
of "Black, Brown, and
"Beautiful," Summer Strawberry,
along with her daddy, Everett.
Hi.
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hello, hi.
- How you doing?
- Oh my gosh, y'all are both so cute.
I'm gonna lead with that.
Also, Summer, tell us more
about how this all got started.
- Yes, so I am black,
brown, and beautiful.
I'm a winner, I'm a
leader, and I am fearless.
- [Kelly] I love it.
(crowd clapping)
- I just started when I was very little,
and I started drawing very young,
and that was around three years old.
And then I started
getting into digital art
when I was around eight years old,
and now I use my iPad Pro.
And so one day, my dad asked why
I wasn't drawing black or brown girls,
and I didn't even realize.
And I was surprised when he asked me that,
and I thought it was
really hard drawing them
because of all the features and the hair.
And once I gave it a try,
I realized it wasn't as
hard as I thought it was.
- And so it reminded me of the
black doll, white doll test
done in 1939, in which
the psychologist asked
the black children which
doll was the prettiest,
which was the nicest,
which was the smartest.
And they all chose the white doll.
And then he asked them
which doll was the bad doll,
which doll was the ugly doll,
and the black children
chose the black doll.
And so to me, it was like more
of a subconscious self-hate
that was coming about.
And so I asked Summer to go ahead
and remove a lot of
the color from her art,
and what she was left with was line art
that represented now a coloring book.
- Oh my gosh.
That's, I didn't even know about that.
What you just talked
about; that's horrible.
But Summer, you include affirmations
in the book as well, right?
That's super important.
- Yes, because affirmations is how I dealt
with my bullying and how
I overcame my bullying.
And I was bullied from the
fourth through sixth grade,
and kids would ask why
my fingers were so long,
and they would compare
their fingers to mine.
And I was also bullied about my tooth
because once I lost my tooth,
it grew in pretty crooked.
And the affirmations
have definitely helped
me overcome my bullying.
And now I'm coming out
with a second coloring book
called "Glow Up," and it'll be translated
in English, Spanish, Portuguese, French,
Haitian, Creole, and Swahili.
- [Kelly] Wow.
And we'll also have two
activity pages included.
So one is talking about the
transatlantic slave trade.
And one is another one where
you could write your own affirmations.
(crowd cheering)
- That's such a cool thing to
be doing at such a young age.
Girl, I'm so proud of you.
Thank you so much, Summer.
Thank you, Everett.
I'm liking y'all's post right now.
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pin, makers of G2,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, wow.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Thank y'all so much.